des vaisseaux volants sont peut être
impressionnant mr heckmann mais regarde
les choses en face tu matraquera jamais
la confiance et la piètre doublure de
l'intelligence
[Musique]
perso je ne sens pas trop
sonic toi tu as ta vitesse pour déplacer
mais nous avec m'a dit on est
complètement fichue bon vous écrabouillé
supportant soutien
pas de panique j'ai la solution qu'il
nous faut
je m'attendais pas ça bon d'accord je
m'attendais à l'inattendu donc c'est moi
qui gagne
[Musique]
ce match
c
c'est le pack
[Musique]
et
youpi
[Musique]
quoi
allez
non non non laisse pas attraper aller
non
[Musique]
à temps
oh
est ce que je peux te donner le conseil
de robotnik à fils et ne courent pas ça
n'en sera que plus douloureux il se fait
mal aux articulations se prouver okc man
tu veux de la vitesse tu vas en avoir
il choisit le duel
les clignotants sanofi ou quoi
ok comme on se retrouve on en a traversé
et sacrée épreuve maintenant vous
comprenez pourquoi un docteur
excentrique food robotique est en train
de coursayres il semble supersonique
vous voulez connaître la fin c'est parti
[Musique]
mais comment c'est possible personne ne
m'avait jamais rattrapé avant
[Musique]
excusez moi monsieur
la foi est libre c'est le moment de
mettre les gaz
j'arrive pas à le sauver
là
bon bah s'il veut pas me lâcher je vais
me cacher
à ces perdu contact visuel
je dois pas le droit d'aller là-haut si
tout est superbe et du monde
[Musique]
il s'appelait sonic
lité chez lui ici
c'était mon ami
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est à toi sonic
recul et s'il vous plaît
je crois que tu as quelque chose qui
m'appartient
[Musique]
ce super pouvoirs est à moi est plus
jamais je ne l'utiliserai pour fuir
maintenant je veux m'en servir pour
protéger mes amis
[Musique]
danilo
ça tue pas le bel et bien un scoop pour
toi eggman c'est pas moi qui vais
quitter la terre c'est toi le seigneur
des donuts
[Musique]
je t'avais dit y arriverait non on l'a
fait à deux
[Musique]
et de deux
es21 non plus fait pas de mal
il en fait pas un peu beaucoup la
est bien derrière moi
oui
j'en fais ce que tu veux
tu penses que mason va bientôt livrer
s'est collé avec 7 buts
[Musique]
alors ça c'était vraiment un mauvais
plan qu'est ce qui m'a pris
il va
vite
et où par dc
approche toi pourquoi je vais tenter un
truc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sonic
crois que j'ai gagné une vie
supplémentaire
vitale fait ça sonic 1 le méga tendent
ces héros je suis trop forte à vie mais
comment tu peux être encore en vie j'en
ai pas la moindre idée